the internet cannot get enough of your  great conversation with zendaya i loved  doing it with her she's a formidable  human being just incredibly powerful and  incredibly humble and deeply talented  and emotionally intelligent and caring  i'm like where did where are you burying  the bodies and because like what's going  on like two perfect yeah yeah yeah who  have you murdered and when is that gonna  come out she's a remarkable person and  fun you know what i mean like she's  she's all that and incredibly  fun to talk to and hang with and deep  and yeah i just i admire her so much as  an actor as an artist  for you two together next i mean listen  i've brought some headshots with me  tonight  no i'm kidding no i don't have any  headshots